(laughs)
- We...
This is so fuckin' weird.
(upbeat music)
- We are putting bacteria on our body.
(lively music)
Just the thought that I'm
gonna be a living host
to other living things is
a weird thought for me.
- I'm skeptical.
- It's magical basically, and
I'm really excited about it.
(lively music)
- Can't use deodorant?
Oh, that's gonna suck.
(lively music)
- You just throw to me.
I'll catch it. (laughs)
- This is the Mother Dirt AO Mist.
- It looks, like, very intense.
- The bacteria in this spray
is called ammonia oxidizing bacteria,
and they consume irritating
components in sweat
and convert them into beneficial
ingredients for the skin.
- It says I'm to expect
a reduced dependency
on soap, shampoo, and
deodorant, as well as
a more hydrated, balanced,
and less irritated skin.
- So there is a shampoo,
and there is a cleanser
that you can use in tandem with this
that I'm guessing--
- I'm not super optimistic,
but you know what?
I'll try anything once, apparently.
(classical music)
- Today we are gonna put bacteria
on me for the first time.
- (sniffs) Didn't use deodorant today.
- This is weird.
- Scalp, (spritzing)
face, (spritzing)
armpits, (spritzing)
(screams)
(spritzing, snorting)
hands, (spritzing)
package...
(spritzing)
(laughs)
- Okay!
All right.
Sprayed my groin, sprayed it.
- I think hopefully within a couple days,
it will start working.
It's the end of day one and
all day I've been thinking,
"Oh, like, this is working great.
I don't smell bad at all."
But I just took my clothes
off and smelled my armpits,
and they smell really bad.
- I don't smell good right now
(laughs)
- How does Jen smell?
I feel like Jen could never smell bad.
- Jen always smells nice.
[Woman] She always smells
- She has really good, like,
[Woman] a little angel.
detergent or something. (laughs)
- I just woke up, and usually,
when I just wake up,
my skin is pretty oily.
Right now, though, it actually feels
pretty moisturized.
And the funny thing is, like,
it feels really smooth.
- This actually isn't that bad.
Once I get over the mental gap of
knowing that there's millions of
little creatures that
now call my body home.
- I just noticed that my armpits are
a different color than
the rest of my body.
They're like, red.
And it kind of looks like a rash.
- I'm no longer using
Mother Dirt products.
And I actually feel like they had a
positive effect on my skin.
- Yesterday I did get a compliment
on my skin.
And I was like, "oh,
is it the Mother Dirt?"
- I don't know if my skin changed.
I think my skin pretty
much stayed the same.
- I'm not sure that my body
reacted well enough to the product
to be able to forgo deodorant.
I don't think I smelled good.
I think anyone that was near me
when I stretched was
pretty unhappy about it.
- Yeah, I would say like,
the first three days
it was pretty smelly, and
by the end of the week,
it had adjusted and everything was good.
- I do not think I could do this again.
It was just a little bit too much for me
to bear smelling the way I did.
Granted, Jen and Macy
thought I smelled fine.
- Would I do this again? Maybe. Maybe.
Y'know, who knows?
We do all kinds of crazy.
We're crazy kids.
(piano note)
(lounge music)
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh, yeah. Mmhm.
(upbeat music)
Hmm.
You don't know the half of it!
(lounge music)